man the trailer that came out on
christmas day for spider-man no way home
was amazing also the second trailer that
came out on tom holland's birthday
oh so incredible my favorite trailer
though the one after the day after loki
oh that was amazing i can't believe toby
showed up in all three trailers i know
they did not hide
anything from him the whole ending scene
for one of them was crazy
hey look at this from consequently
spider-man
trailer update where is it let's see
what he has to say this should be a fun
discussion
yeah i have i i have it on decent
authority on when to expect it
and um yeah let's sprinkle in some
talking points
yeah let's tease that much later on
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
hello warren i have been getting a ton
of questions about the spider-man
no way home trailer spiderboy people
have been asking for an
update so here we are last week an
official
verified twitter account of somebody who
works inside of the industry
claimed that the trailer would be coming
out on june 10th he was very very
thanos he stated multiple times that the
trailer was
indeed coming on the 10th and since he
had such a good reputation it made a lot
of sense as to why people would think
yes the trailer is coming out this day
this combined with a picture going
around that showed an amc
logo and it showed the spider-man no way
home trailer release date set for the
10th led us to believe that yes the
trailer was coming today i will say that
we live in la there's a lot of amc's out
here
it's easy to become friends with people
who work at amc
especially if you're in this line of
work that you see us
in and yes i can personally confirm that
theaters have it
yeah so it's there right but it's i
believe what they
have a situation where it's like
passcode protected so
people who even have the theaters can't
even view it yeah oh they'll
remotely release it so that then they
can show it however for those saying
that it could still come today
very very unlikely but except yesterday
particularly sony has had a track record
recently of releasing things very early
on in the morning
typically 9 a.m eastern time and 6 a.m
pacific time
they released the venomous therapy
carnage trailer this is also the time
that they released the eternals trailer
so we can probably safely assume that if
the trailer was going to be released
today it would already be out
now if you want to know who this person
is you can check my last spider-man
update josh that no sweat i'm not trying
to give this guy a lot of hate so i
won't mention him by name
let's just get it in there one more time
so many times it's in the video now it's
in the that's what i'm here to do
i get words protecting him this is just
a good showcase for warren's character
all right warren's a good guys
way to indirectly make me look like a
terrible human being warranty
yeah i'm just like josh that'll swipe
josh keep saying
totes you feel like the villain now and
it's staying in the video everyone
follow
josh thanos web he's trying his best i
follow him give him some love give him
some love he is a hard worker that guy
but he did stick to his story that he
did indeed hear it was coming on the
10th from a very reliable source
so things could have changed now
yesterday this was very interesting
the official spider-man no way home
twitter account
did comment on a spider-man trailer meme
they actually retweeted it
quoting it now the meme oh yeah i saw
that
countdown and it was this meme right
here the classic meme of the car
changing directions really really
quickly to get off on the exit with the
sign above stating
exit right oh my gosh it's coming today
at 9am eastern time
or go to the left slash straight which
is don't guess and just wait for the
trailer
but what does exit 12 what is it with 12
years
12 spiderman yeah there's going to be 12
multiple versus
spiderman at least sinister 6 times 2 is
12.
so there's gonna be two sinister sixes
and they're all on the left
look i i think it's coming out closer to
black widow it just makes more sense
that it would be doing that if it comes
out earlier
great that's amazing if it comes out for
peter rabbit let's move
to it i don't care if it comes out early
that's awesome but i feel like it's
exceptionally more likely to come out
during black widow
obviously sometimes we'll get the word
on some trailers that come
out we're on top of them when some
scoopers have reported them because
there's a couple of sources that we have
who
don't always hit us up but once in a
while they do from what i'm hearing
is closer to black widow is the current
plan so
that's that tracks that just makes more
sense if you do this everyone's going to
be talking about
spider-man and that's what they're going
to be thinking about so you might get
more people to go into theaters to watch
it during black widows
black widow's been pushed back so far
like they could probably use the extra
height boost
and especially because it's going to be
on premier access as well
and people are going to want to see that
trailer in the theaters and the official
spider-man no way home code account said
please keep left quote tweeting it now
this is very interesting because
they quote tweeted this yesterday and
the meme was posted five days ago
so that means that sony was very well
aware that people
expected the trailer to come out today
on the 10th and this was kind of
now i don't want to do too many of these
trailer update videos
because i only want to do them if we
truly find out some information or if
there's a good reliable source stating
they think they know when the trailer is
coming
i have two persons you keep doing them
for
trailers who are pretty much 100 correct
when they tell me a trailer is coming
out
i checked with them yesterday i checked
with them again today and my update for
you is
they haven't heard anything so i don't
expect it to come out within the next
day or so
it's your source share sources
indeed have the trailer in the cinema so
we are on the brink of it coming out it
could be any time now perhaps it was
supposed to be today but they moved it
back because they didn't want to release
it the day after loki premiered because
let's face it when the trailer finally
does come out it's pretty much all
anybody is going to be talking about
that's not a last-minute decision though
but i promise you i'm always looking and
listening for any hint when the trailer
could drop so if i do
hear anything that is legitimate i'll be
sure to do an update video
but if i don't hear anything i won't be
doing a video so if you don't see me
post
i don't know anything just being honest
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on the videos when i do know something
don't forget to like the video leave
your comments down below and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
thank you for putting this together i
think you gotta triple down on your
spider-man videos buddy yeah
once a day at least once a day twice a
day
i'm cool with that dude trailer release
date theories
i just love the conversations that are
happening man
when's the trailer what are we hearing
what might be true then when the trailer
comes out
oh my god let's break this down easter
eggs all that it's just like what's the
next trailer
sometimes the sizzle can be more fun
than the actual product and isn't that a
sad fact
oh yeah anticipation is a fascinating
part of the process
we love looking forward to stuff yeah
yeah and we love decoding
things in advance and yet hoping that
somehow they're more mind-blowing than
what we've like
yes through to find but guys you best
bet that we
are checking tirelessly even yesterday i
didn't fully believe it was
like i was like it was eighty percent
not
going to come out that and but still i
was
up at six seven eight just kept checking
and kept checking
and then uh yeah i really messed up my
sleep schedule for that keep a lookout
for when we do cover it guys subscribe
to warren if you haven't done so already
not only does he cover spider-man videos
five times a day he also covers a lot of
different marvel related content
recently started doing some dc stuff
he's got
awesome breakdowns and such too so yeah
and plus he's just a great human being
love you ward i love you i love you
patriot of the day shout out
fox i wanted to give you an update this
is literally it's so in the office 24
hours a day
we don't cross massage but i use mine at
home all the time
this is incredible every time i use it
first time chills every single time
and also i treated myself to a
tempurpedic pillow
spent eight months saving up to buy that
pillow
fifty dollars oh man that's uh that's an
egg
are you sure you can afford that and i
have the purple silk sheet all over
silk yeah butter it feels freaking so
nice
fox you are incredible you are foxy and
i mean that
in a in a non coming on to you way yeah
like you're
you're cunning like a fox i mean just in
a friendly complementary way because
majestic you know i can get in trouble
if i'm coming across so forward
you know i could still get in trouble
even if i'm clarifying that because that
could have just made you feel
uncomfortable by saying you're [ __ ]
any compliment at all yeah yeah many
compliments could have got me in trouble
you're all right in most respects you're
a good human being you're a quality
person josh thanos webb josh